ce que j'ai vu hier dans le débat
mélenchon zemmour c'est qu'on avait d'un
côté un candidat politique aguerri à cet
exercice du débat politique et de la
présentation d'un programme et en face
un polémiste qui a du mal à enlever le
costume de polémiste pour rentrer dans
la peau l'élu d'un candidat avec des
outrances dont il nous a déjà habitué je
voulais montrer un premier extrait où il
parle de djihad plutôt que de
délinquance là on est vraiment dans le
zemmour traditionnel plutôt que zemmour
candidats
la délinquance que nous vivons n'est pas
une délinquance c'est un jihad
c'est une guerre qui nous ait mené une
guerre de civilisation
une guerre de pillage une guerre de vol
une guerre de viol est une guerre de
deux meurtres le pente non j'ai pas
honte du tout je vais vous dire dans les
métros parisiens on a fait un élan caire
10 77 et 75 % vous aurez pas ranger chat
surtout voulu vous monsieur mélenchon
foot mais vous et moi qui s'est passé
que vos chiffres mans vous embêtant mais
ces communes ont ils me jettent jeudi le
jeu mais non nous d'accord non non la
ville crime je les reconnais c'est pas
le sujet mais si c'est pour le sujet csn
de saint-louis l'analyse alors justement
alors vous voulez vous répéter comme un
an mais la parole c'est les musulmans
c'est les musulmans où il gît al de chez
moi j'ai manque de parler comme a dit
tout et on veut bien qu'il a du mal
effectivement eric zemmour à sortir de
cette ancienne qu'il a sur l'islam les
musulmans la délinquance qui est un
djihad là ça le dessert est complètement
qu'il veut pas aussi wii voit que ça
marche en fait avait fait ça depuis 15
ans plus le plus grand de l'état
larvaire oui mais ça marche je pense
aussi pour l'instant convoyer les
sondages il a dit pour sandra je dire
mélenchon lui baisse à lui pour s'en
fabrique il s'en vend dans le même
étiage tous les deux mais eric zemmour
pousse ça il va jamais en changer je
pense à la compagnie bell comme ça si
tenté qu'il fasse une campagne et le
souci c'est qu'il part peut-être un peu
tôt et les gens en place et peut-être
par ces mots risation ce refrain
l'impression que zemmour a remplacé le
mot kovy doucet depuis un an et demi on
n'empêche que ça maintenant on n'entend
plus que zemmour toute la journée dans
cette phrase vous quoi qu'on parle il
pleut c'est zemmour il fait beau c'est
émouvant chiffres mélenchon parler de
disque rayé en dix ans on a l'impression
que vous dites tout le temps la même
chose et c'est vrai ça marchait quand il
avait son émission quand ils assez
tribune dans le figaro mais là quand il
est question d'un débat politique il
faut rentrer dans les thèmes du débat
faut s'adapter faut avoir des arguments
et là c'est évidemment tout le temps les
mêmes et tout le temps l'autre ans